ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะผู้หญิงคะวันนี้
วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วันพุธค่ะ
วันนี้วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 9 ค่ะวันนี้วันพุธวันที่ 9 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมค่ะเดือน
มีนาคม
ปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะเกย์พ.คก็ขอ
2565 ค่ะปีพต
2556  5  5  5 นะคะวันนี้วันพุธนะคะตอน
นี้เวลา
รหักเวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
4 โมง
38 นาทีค่ะตอนนี้เวลา 4 โมง
38 นาทีนนะคะ 04:38 มะเป็น
PM ไหมคะ
ถ้า p.a.m. ภาพ PM กี่โมงเป็น
04:38 ลาทีค่ะ 4 โมง 38 นาทีนนะคะครู
หญิงคะวันนี้มีนะนักเรียนกี่คนคะ
วันนี้มีนักเรียน 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8
มีนักเรียน 8 คนค่ะครูเอ๋นักเรียนนัก
เรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียน
นักเรียนนักเรียน
8 คนนะคะที่มีครูกี่คนคะ
นี่ครู 2 คนค่ะมีครู 2 คนนะคะครูนักเรียน
ครูป 2 คนเป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชาย
โปร 2 คนเป็นผู้หญิงค่ะครูผู้หญิงคนเป็น
ผู้หญิงนะคะอ่ะ
คุณครูหญิงคะมีครูผู้หญิง 2 คน
แล้วนักเรียน
มีนักเรียนผู้หญิงกี่คนคะ
นี่นะนักเรียนผู้หญิง
2 คนค่ะมีนักเรียนผู้หญิง 2 คนมีนัก
เรียนผู้ชายกี่คนคะ
มีนักเรียนผู้ชาย 6 คนค่ะมีนักเรียนผู้
ชายคบคนนะคะนักเรียนผู้หญิงสองคน
นักเรียนผู้ชาย 6 คนมีนักเรียนทั้งหมดกี่
คนคะมีนักเรียนทั้งหมด 8 คนค่ะไปนักเรียน
ทั้งหมด 8 คนนะคะผมขอ
ครูหญิงรู้จักนักเรียนไหมคะนี่ผู้หญิงไม่
รู้จักนักเรียนค่ะครูเอ๋
ครูเอ๋รู้จักนักเรียนไหมคะครูเอ๋ไม่รู้
จักนักเรียน
บอกวันนี้วันที่ 1 ครูหญิงครูเอ๋เห็นนะคะ
ตาลอ่ะเห็นนักเรียน
วันที่ 1 ไม่รู้จักนักเรียน
ครูชื่อเอ๋
ครูผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะอ่ะใส่นั้นครูมีกระดาษ
นะครูมีกระดาษก่อนอ่ะกระดาษคู่เอกก็ทำ
อะไรคะผู้หญิงอาทิครูเอ๋ทำอะไรคะปูเอกพับ
กระดาษ
อ๋อเก็บพับกระดาษแล้วทำอะไรคะน่ะอากูเอส
พี 498
[เพลง]
1 แผ่น 2 แผ่นละคู่เอกก็จะพับกระดาษอีก
กูแอบพับกระดาษแล้วทำอะไรคะกูเอกก็ขี่
กระดาษ
ที่อีกใช่ไหมคะอีกตัวเองนะมีกระดาษกระดาษ
อะไรคะ
ทั้งหมด 4 แผ่นหรือ 1  2
3  4
คู่เองคิดเอากระดาษให้นักเรียนแต่ไม่ได้
เพราะว่าที่นี่สูงวีดีโอ
ไม่ได้งั้นครูเอ๋กระดาษให้ครูเอ๋ราคาแล้ว
ครูเอ๋ทำอะไรก็มีกระดาษนี่ปากกา
นะคะอาจจะพาหาคู่ f เปิดปากกาก่อนนะคะผู้
หญิงกนิษฐาเป็นฝาปากกาอันนี้เป็นดามนะคะ
คู๋
ดึงนะจริงนะเอาฝาวาง
กับกระดาษแผ่นที่ 1 ปากกาเหม็น
กระดาษแผ่นที่ 1  5
เขียนชื่อครูเอ๋
ชื่อ
เก๋นะฮะโอเค
8 ได้ไหมอ่ะเดี๋ยวนะคะโอเคหาก่อนผู้หญิง
หาอะไรคะครูเอ๋เอ๋หา
โอเคนะ
ทำอะไรคะ
ถ้ามีคนไทยเรียกแม็ค
แม็ควิสเห็นไหมอ่ะกูเอกก็แม็กซ์ติดไว้
ชื่อชื่อชื่อเก๋
หึงผู้หญิง
มีผู้หญิงเขียนชื่อตัวเองเขียนที่กระดาน
ก็ได้กระดานเอาตอนแก่โอเคแต่
ครูหญิงก็มีกระดาษนะคะครูเอ๋มีกระดาษใช่
ไหมแต่ผู้หญิงมีแม็กไหมหรือผู้หญิงไม่มี
แม็กซ์
ผู้หญิงไม่ต้องเขียนแบบครูเอ๋อ่ะผู้หญิง
เขียนที่กระดานเป็นเขียนที่กระดานนะคะ
นี่
ครูชิรูด์ชื่อหญิงค่ะครูชื่อหญิงครูชื่อ
เอ๋
นะเรียนอีก 8 คนชื่ออะไรคะ
เอาผู้ชายก่อนนะคะค่ะเดี๋ยวกูอ่านดูนะอ่า
นักเรียนมีกระดาษใช่ไหมคะมีกระดาษกระดาษ
ทุกคนมีกระดาษนะหากกระดาษกระดาษที่ 1 นัก
เรียนเขียน
เขียนชื่อชื่อของตัวเองนะคะ
เขียนแล้วผู้หญิงคะนักเรียนคนที่ 1 ผู้
ชายค่ะนักเรียนคนที่ 1 ผู้ชายนักเรียน
ชื่อชื่ออะไรคะครูเอ๋นักเรียนเขียนว่า
Black  Black
[เพลง]
คุณแรสนะคะคนที่ 1 ชื่อคุณแล้สนะคะอ๋อนัก
เรียนคนที่ 2 ค่ะผู้หญิงเขียนต้องแม่แล้ว
ค่ะนักเรียนถ้าเป็นผู้ผู้ชายเนาะวันนี้ 2
5 คนที่ 2 ผู้ชายค่ะอาจจะไปคุณโรเบิร์ต
คุณโรเบิร์ตคุณโรเบิร์ตผู้หญิงกระดานมี
สำหรับนักเรียน 8 คนโอเคไหมใช่ค่ะโอเค
ชื่อผู้หญิงใหญ่ไปหน่อยค่ะนักเรียน
อ่ะนักเรียนคนที่ 3 ค่ะอ่า
เนื้อเพลงคนที่ 3 เป็นผู้ชายใช่ไหมคะคน
ที่ 3 ผู้ชายค่ะกูหญิงชื่อทาดาชิ
ทาดา
ชิมาเขียน
ทั่วค่ะชื่อดาราอาทินักเรียนคนที่ 4 ผู้
ชายค่ะผู้หญิง
ในเล็กคนที่ 4 ผู้ชายชื่ออะไรคะนักเลงคน
ที่ 4 ชื่อชื่อคุณจอห์นมีวงจรที่คุณ John
นะคะนักเรียนคนที่ 5 กับผู้หญิงแสดงคนที่
5 เป็นผู้ชายชื่ออะไรคะครูเอ๋คนที่ถ้า
ไม่ใช่ผู้ชายผู้หญิง
ขอโทษค่ะ
นักเรียนก็มี 8 คนไม่ใช่เหรอคะใช่อ่ะคน
ที่จะเร่งคนที่ข้างฉันเอาชื่อขึ้นมาให้
ครูเห็นเนี่ยเป็นผู้หญิงโหเป็นผู้หญิง
ขึ้น Lisa
ปุ๋ย
SA ไหมคะ Hi นักศึกษาผู้หญิงเป็นผู้ชาย
หรือผู้หญิงคะครูเอ๋เป็นผู้หญิงค่ะ
ชื่ออะไรคะชื่อคุณอะไรนะอ๋อประวีณา
คุณ of ปราวีณาเหรออ่าอ่ะอ่ะอามีนานะคะ
นักเรียนคนที่เท่าไหร่แล้วคะวันที่ 8
แล้วค่ะนักเรียนคนสุดท้ายถูกไหมคะ 1  2  3
4  5  6  7  5 คนที่ 8 ใช่ไหมคะคนที่ 7
เธอคู๋ขอโทษค่ะ 2  3  4  5  6  7 คนที่ 7
ค่ะครูเอ๋ก็เมาวันที่ 7 นะคะอ่ะชื่ออื้อ
คุณเท
นักเรียนคนที่เจ็ดเป็นผู้ชายนะพลเท t  a
s  t  e ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะคุณทอี
คนที่ 8 ชื่ออะไรคะอ๋อนักเลงคนที่ 8 ชื่อ
คุณ John เหมือนกันหนูก็จะแต่เป็น JA จร
อ่านชายจองเห
รียญ 8 คนนะคะมีชื่ออะไรบ้างนะคะมีผู้
หญิงคนที่ 1 คุณ Rap ค่ะคนที่ 2 คุณโร
เบิร์ตค่ะคนที่ 3 คุณทาดาชิค่ะคนที่ 4
คุณ John คนที่ 5 คุณลิซ่าคนที่ 6 คุณ
ปวีณาคุณปวีณาค่ะคนที่ 7 ที่ชื่ออะไรคะ
คุณแต่ยีค่ะคนที่ 8 ชื่ออะไรคะคุณ John
ค่ะอ๋อมีอะเอามี 8 คนนะคะขอบคุณนะคะอ่ะ
อ่ะทีนี้กระดาษแผ่นที่ 2 คู๋จะเขียน
นามสกุล
งูเนื้อมีชื่อแล้วก็ต้องมีน้ำสกุลค่ะเอ๋
ชื่อเอ๋
นามสกุลอุ้ยย
อุ้ยทำไมหมึกไม่มีเดี๋ยวคุยหาหมดก่อนนะ
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงก็เลื่อนนักเรียนลงมานิดนึง
ค่ะจะได้เขียนนามสกุลได้
ของผู้หญิงเล่นได้ด้วยหรอคะลบค่ะ
เขียนเป็น 8 คนก็ได้
โอเคกู้หญิงเห็นไหมอ่ะ
ไม่เห็นเอาเห็นแล้วค่ะนามสกุลครูเอ๋ค่ะ
ครูชื่อเอ๋นามสกุลสมสมัย
ค่ะ
นามสกุลสมสมัยนะคะ
หลังชื่ออะไรนะคะครูชื่อหญิงค่ะนามสกุล
อะไรคะนามสกุล
วงศ์คำภู
ชื่อนามสกุลวงศ์คำพูห์นะคะ
ผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวกูแอบดูนักเรียนนักเรียน
เขียนนะคะเขียนชื่อเสร็จแล้วเขียนนามสกุล
นะคะเขียนนามสกุลอ้าผู้หญิงจะดูใครคะเอา
ใครก่อนคุณใครยกก่อนคะตัวเองคุณแร้คอา
คุณแบรสต์นามสกุลอะไรคะครูเองคุณพิศ
คลิปใส่
อ๋ออ๋อคุณแมทท์นามสกุลพิษนะคะคนที่ 1
คุณโรเบิร์ตน้ำสกุลอะไรคะ
อะไรคะคุณโรเบิร์ตเขียนแล้วอ่ะคุณโร
เบิร์ตยกค่ะยกยกครูเห็นแล้วคุณโรเบิร์ต
นามสกุลพระชิสันดีค่ะ
คุณโรเบิร์ตนามสกุลแพททินสันแล้วใครยกคน
ที่ 3 คะครูเองอาทิยกแล้วค่ะคุณ Thailand
ชิคุณธนิยกแล้วอ่ะคุณธาราชินามสกุลอะไรคะ
ครูเอ๋คุณทาดาชินามสกุลนากาสึกค่ะตอ
นากาสึนะคะ
ลูกไหมคะครูเอ๋ถูกค่ะอ่า
คนคุณ John คุณ John ยกนามสกุลเหมือนกัน
ยกป้ายนามสกุลคุณ John  J  ohn สอน jom
นามสกุลชูเมกเกอร์ค่ะ
สูตร maker นะคะสาค่า
เอาคุณ John นามสกุล chul กเกอร์ High ๆ
คน Lisa ยกแล้วผู้หญิงอายกแล้วชื่อแล้ว
คุณนิชั่นนามสกุลเฉินค่ะฉันสน 4  ce  En
ใช่ค่ะฉันค่ะ
คุณประวีณาค่ะอะคุณปวีณายกแล้วค่ะ
คุณปวีณานามสกุลอะไรคะนามสกุลสิ่งค่ะ
s  s  i  n  g  e  s หรือเปล่าคะที่จะ
จี่
ให้ค่ะใช่ใช่โอเคอ่ะเหลือ 2 คนแล้ว 2 คน
คุณเทคุณเทนามสกุลอะไรคะ
คุณทอียกแล้วคุณ shaishi นามสกุลคิมค่ะ
อ๋อคุณ Jae  Hee นามสกุลคิมค่ะคน
1-8 แล้วค่ะคุณ John คุณ John คะนามสกุล
อะไรคะ
คุณ John ยกกระดาษแล้วคุณ John นามสกุล
โอลอฟค่ะ o  o  l  o  f
คนจรโอนหรอ
เราก็รู้ชื่อใช่ไหมชื่อ
นามสกุล
นะคะอ่าชื่อนามสกุลครูชื่อนามสกุลนัก
เรียนแล้วผู้หญิงกูอะไรคะมีกระดาษแผ่นที่
3 กระดาษแผ่นที่ 3 ทำอะไรคะครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋
นะฮะคนไทย
คนไทย
คู๋ใหญ๋เป็นคนไทยผู้หญิงเป็นคนประเทศใช่
ไหมคะครูหญิงเป็นคนไทยค่ะ
เป็นผลไทยยนะคะเป็นโอนไทยนะคะเราถามเป็น
คนประเทศอะไรครูเอ๋เป็นคนไทยอ่ะแต่นัก
เรียน
นักเรียนอ่ะเป็นคนประเทศอะไร
บางทีถามคนประเทศอะไรบางทีถามมาจากสะมะ
บัตเทศไทยนักเรียนมามามาประเทศไทยมาจาก
ประเทศอะไร
คู๋รู้หนึ่งคนคุยหนิงรู๋รู้ใครคะเอรู้จัก
คุณทาดาชินากาสึก
คุณทาดาชินากาสื่อมาจากประเทศอะไรคะครู
เอกคิดคุณคิดคุณทาดาชิมาจากประเทศญี่ปุ่น
อ๋อ
ใช่ไหมคะ
คุณถ่ายแล้วที่บอกให้ใช่ใช่อ่าขอ
คุณทาดาชิมาจากประเทศญี่ปุ่นค่ะ
รู้แล้วเพียงชนผู้หญิงเขียนได้ไหมคะ
ญี่ปุ่นขีดไปก็ได้ข้างๆ R ญี่ปุ่นนะคะคุณ
บุญทัน
มาจากประเทศอะไรนะคะ
ญี่ปุ่นค่ะมาจากประเทศญี่ปุ่นนะคะอ่ะต่อ
ไปคู่หญิงอยากจะรู้ว่าอยากรู้ใครคะ
อยากรู้คุณโรเบิร์ตค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตคุณโร
เบิร์ตมาจากประเทศอะไรคะคุณระเบิดเขียนนะ
คะ
อ้อมคุณโรเบิร์ตบอกว่าคุยอ่านออก
มาจากประเทศอังกฤษค่ะคน Robert มาจาก
ประเทศอังกฤษ
ประเทศอังกฤษใช่ค่ะอะต่อไปค่ะคู๋อยากรู้
อยากรู้คุณ Black พิษค่ะคุณแบรดพิตต์มา
จากประเทศอะไรคะครูเอ๋คุณแม็คพิษออกคุณ
แม่ผิดบอกว่ามาจากประเทศอเมริกา
[เพลง]
มาจากประเทศอเมริกานะคะค่ะผู้หญิงหญิง
อยากรู้
รู้ว่าใครมาจากประเทศอะไรคะผู้หญิงอยาก
รู้คุณลิซ่าค่ะค่ะคุณรีคุณลิคุณนิซ่ายก
ค่ะ
อ๋อคุณลิซ่ามาจากประเทศจีนโอ้นี่วันค่ะ
บริซ่ามาจากไต้หวัน
ประเทศไต้หวันนะคะ
ครูเอ๋อยากรู้
คุณประวีณา
คุยกับวีณาคุณปวีณายกแล้วผู้หญิงมองเห็น
ไหมคะคุณปวีณาเขียนว่าอะไร
เห็นอ้ะคุณปวีณามาจากประเทศอินเดีย
คุณประวีณามาจากประเทศอินเดียใส่ค่ะ
โอเคอ่ะครูเอ๋คะคุณ John คุณ John
ชูเมกเกอร์มาจากประเทศอะไรคะคุณ John ยก
กระดาษด้วยค่ะ
ประเทศอะไรอ่ะอ๋อเก็บว่าอเมริกา
[เพลง]
นี้นะคะอเมริกาแล้วก็ครูเอ๋คะคุณ tatty
มาจากประเทศอะไรคะคุณแตที่นามสกุลอะไรนะ
คุณแตฮีคิมนามสกุลคิมอุนตานามสกุลคิม
คุณแตฮีมาจากประเทศอะไรคะ
ขอบคุณคุณ tatty ยกแล้วมาจากประเทศ
เกาหลีค่ะ
แล้วก็คนสุดท้ายคุณจอห์นโอลาฟคุณจอนผมสวย
มากค่ะมากชอบค่ะมาจากประเทศอะไรคะครูเอ๋
คุณจอต่อคุณจอห์นยกให้ดูแล้วคุณจอห์นมา
จากประเทศสวีเดน
จะ
เล่นโอเค
หรือผู้หญิงคะตอนนี้เราก็รู้จักอะไรนะ
ชื่อนะครับชื่อ
นามสกุลนะคะของนักเรียนรู้ว่ามาจากประเทศ
อะไรนะคะผู้หญิงคะเดี๋ยวเราทวนนะคะเรามี
นักเรียนกี่คนคะเรามี Navi นักเรียน 8 คน
ค่ะคนมีคนอเมริกากี่คนคะมีคนอเมริกา
122 คนค่ะมีคนอเมริกา 2 คนเป็นผู้หญิง
หรือผู้ชาย
เป็นผู้ชาย 2 คนค่ะเป็นผู้ชายอเมริกา 2
คนนะคะอะเรามีคนญี่ปุ่นกี่คนคะ
มีคนญี่ปุ่น 1 คนค่ะอ๋อแต่ถ้าเป็นนัก
เรียนญี่ปุ่น 1 คนนักเรียนอเมริกา 2 คนนะ
คะเป็นคนเอานาฬิกากับคนญี่ปุ่นแล้วเรามี
คนเกาหลีกี่คนคะ
มีคนเกาหลี 1 คนค่ะมีคนเกาหลี 1 คนมีนะ
เรียนเกาหลี 1 คนนะคะมีนักเรียน
อาจคนอินเดียกี่คนคะมีไหมมีมีค่ะมีคน
อินเดีย 1 คนคนอินเดียเป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้
ชาย
เป็นผู้หญิงค่ะอ่ะคนอินเดียเป็นผู้หญิงมี
อินเดียหนึ่งคนมีคนไต้หวันกี่คนคะมีคน
ไต้หวัน 1 คนค่ะมีคนไต้หวัน 1 คนนี้
ถ้ามีคนอังกฤษไหมคะ
มีค่ะค่ะมีคนอังกฤษ 1 คนเพราะมีคนอังกฤษ 1
คนนะคะแล้วมีคนสวีเดนไหมคะ
มีค่ะมีคนสวีเดนกี่คนมีคนสวีเดน 1 คนคน
สวีเดน 1 คนนะคะอ๋อ
หมดหรือยังหมดแล้วเนาะเออหมดแล้วก็นัก
เรียน 8 คนนะคะมีนักเรียนที่เป็นคน
อเมริกา 2 คนคนที่ปุ่น 1 คนคนไต้หวัน 1
คน
อเมริกา 2 ญี่ปุ่น 1 ไต้หวัน 1 คนคน
อินเดีย
1 คนคนอังกฤษ
แต่ขอ 1 คนสวีเดน
1 คนคนเกาหลี
1 คนก็มีทั้งหมด 8 คนนะคะค่ะเป็นนัก
เรียนนะคะนักเรียนไม่ใช่คนไทยค่ะนักเรียน
เป็นคน
คนอะไรคนต่างประเทศเนาะค้า
ต่างประเทศนะคะ 8 คนนะครับ 8 คนโง่อ่ะคู่
a ถามวันนี้นะกูเอ๋ถามอะไรนักเรียนบ้าง
คะผู้หญิงผู้ a ถามนักเรียน
1 ครูเหมถามนักเรียนชื่ออะไรชื่ออะไร
ราคาอันที่สองครูเอ๋ถามว่าอะไรคะคู๋ถาม
ว่านักเรียนนามสกุลอะไรอ่ะแล้วอันที่สาม
อาเจ๊ถามอะไรคะครูเอ๋ถามว่านักเรียนมาจาก
ประเทศอะไรค่ะการ์ดถามชื่ออะไรนามสกุล
อะไร
มาจากประเทศอะไรนะคะ a ถาม 3 คำถามราคา
ค่ะมีอีกที่นี่ถ้ามีคนดู
ดูนิตานะคะตาแล้วก็ดูวีดีโอ
เป็นนักเรียนครูหญิงอยากรู้ไหม
อยากรู้ค่ะครูเอ๋รู้ว่าอยากรู้อยากรู้ไหม
ว่าชื่ออะไร
อยากรู้นะเรียนชื่ออะไรอยากรู้ไหมคะว่า
นักเรียนนามสกุลอะไร
อยากรู้ค่ะ
แล้วอยากรู้ไหมคะนักเรียนออกมาจากประเทศ
อะไร
ยากรู้ค่ะแล้วก็อยากรู้ไหมนักเรียนเป็น
ผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชาย
เป็น
เลี้ยงผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะหรือผู้ชาย
อยากรู้ค่ะครูเอ๋ทำยังไงล่ะ
comment
comment นะคะ
คอมเม้นท์นักเรียนชื่ออะไรฉันก็พูดเอ๋ถาม
นักเรียนนามสกุลอะไรค่ะนักมาจากประเทศ
อะไร
นะคะมาจากประเทศอะไรนะคะคอมเม้นข้างล่าง
เนาะ
ครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋จะได้รู้จักนักเรียนค่ะ
เพราะว่าคลิปนี้เรามีนักเรียน 8 คนนะคะ
ให้มีนักเรียน 8 คน
มีแต่วีดีโอไม่รู้กูเองไม่รู้นักเรียนดู
กี่คนชื่นอะไรก็เขียนชื่อข้างล่างนะคะ
งั้นนี้นะคะเราก็รู้จักชื่อนามสกุลผู้
หญิงผู้ชายมาจากประเทศอะไรรู้จักครูรู้
จักนักเรียน
โป้ผู้หญิงหมดเวลาแล้วโอโห้
หมดเวลาแล้วเราก็ต้องบ๊ายบายๆนักเรียน
แล้วก็เจอกันคลิปหน้านะคะค่าสวัสดีค่ะดี
ค่ะบ๊ายบาย